We're going to elect that his reelect Lincoln in a moment.
The election of 1864 being one of the without a question crucial turning points
in the war in a war that was so political
but spare the poets.
I want to begin by placing you somewhere.
The ending of the civil war of course
was for thousands upon thousands,
really millions of Americans a confrontation with death on a scale they'd never
known,
never experienced and frankly never have.
Again,
there's a marvelous new book on this,
two new books on this one in particular,
but drew Faust whom you've read already,
a book called the Republic of suffering,
which I recommend to you just came out a couple months ago,
which is all about the deaf culture that the civil war bread,
our greatest death poet was Whitman.
This is risky.
I'm going to actually recite a little piece,
a little bits of what could be women's greatest poem.
At least it is in my view,
but what do I know?
I'm not a literary scholar,
but there are ways in Whitman's one line locks last in the door yard bloom that
he is actually anticipating what's going to happen with time to the problem of
how Americans will remember this ghastly bloodletting.
They've just experiences of course the poem about Lincoln's death.
Woodman really had a thing about Lincoln.
As you may know,
he wrote possibly the only poem that ever rhyme and his magnificent collection,
oh captain,
my captain in relation to Lincoln's death,
but lilacs is a masterpiece.
It's the poem he wrote to try to imagine the funeral train of Abraham Lincoln,
the train that took some
Tony days,
three coffins cause to got damage.
It stopped and I forget now,
1617 different cities and this incredible tour all over New England and then all
across the north and the Midwest.
And finally to his barrier when Springfield,
Illinois
and what a Whitman really wrote here was a kind of a calming,
it's written in a mood of a kind of a calming,
deep politicized contemplation on what Whitman called the fathomless sure
unwinding arms of cool and folding death,
but it's very much directly about Lincoln's death.
And Whitman imagines a song.
Bird calls it a warbling
and he says he hears this warbling singing a solitary song.
His words of the bleeding throat deaths outlet,
song of life for well,
dear brother,
he's speaking to the bird now for well,
I know if thou was not granted to sing though,
what's surely die
and he's trying to use the bird,
go read this poem,
read it three,
four and five times.
He's trying to use the warbling,
the song sparrow as a metaphor for all of America.
How shall I wore here?
It gives voice to the bird.
He even writes lyrics for the bird.
How shall I warble and myself for the dead one that I love,
it's like an offering.
Whitman picks a sprig of Lilac,
he says,
and places Abraham Lincoln's funeral train in the setting of what he calls ever
returning spring across the vast landscape of America from east to the prairie.
It was April like now a little later.
Lilacs were in bloom by late in the month.
And it comes with this magnificent verse over the breast of Spring,
the land,
the mid cities and mid lanes and through old woods where lately the vial,
it's peeped from the ground spotting the grade debris amid the grass in the
fields,
each side of the lanes passing the enlist grass,
passing the yellow speared wheat,
every grain from its shroud and the dark brown fields up risen,
passing the appletree blows of white and pink in the orchards carrying a corpse
to where it shall rest in the grave.
Night and day journey's a coffin.
And then he says,
the bird must sing.
It's Carol of death.
And the poet tries to give words to the music,
yet one senses that even Whitman with all his powers could not match the little
wore blings power to deliver what he calls that powerful psalm.
In the night.
This is a poem of grief for the whole country.
He's trying to capture the meaning of death all at death caused in the civil war
if it's possible.
But he gives the job to a tiny little bird.
Whitman himself,
he says is left visions,
his words,
a battle corpses and the debris of all the slain soldiers of the war in his
head.
The funeral train passes by all the images the poet can muster and then he's
just left to say
his words.
The living remained and suffered.
Now,
um,
I'll return to Whitman.
It's a,
it's one way to get a handle if it is a handle.
I want.
Americans were coping with an 1865,
um,
the level and the scale of sacrifice that they had experienced.
And of course,
Lincoln's assassination came,
uh,
to three days after Robert e Lee's surrender.
It happened,
man.
It's more than that in a minute.
Yeah.
But backup with me,
back up with me and have that last year of the war,
it was still possible for the south to win.
It's version of a victory.
As late as I'd say August of 1864 I suppose you could even say September,
but after the fall of Atlanta,
it wasn't likely,
but now quickly that election of 64 was one of the most important in our
history.
We don't pay a lot of attention to it because we kind of speed by it or around
it and we almost ignore it sometimes.
That's another election.
Let's get on with the civil war.
Yeah.
Across the north,
there was tremendous war weariness.
That summer I mentioned already 65 66,000 casualties in grants army alone in
Virginia.
In two and a half months,
there was great bitterness against the draft that summer.
Uh,
in the end,
only about six,
7% of all union soldiers will actually be drafted.
But there was tremendous resentment against it.
Yeah.
In the north,
there were the peace Democrats or sometimes that's what they were called.
Sometimes they were called copperheads named for the snake.
Copperheads usually though,
are those people who somehow were deemed truly does loyal to the union and
actually we're engaging in machinations and conspiracies to overthrow the union.
That's always been an open question.
There was an effort within the Republican Party is early as May and June of 64
to dump Lincoln and place of either Salmon Chase,
a member of Lincoln's cabinet,
his attorney general,
and read Doris Kearns Goodwin team of rivals.
If you want to know just how much chase was scheming to dump Lincoln as his own
attorney general
face May.
I've had the most daughter in Washington,
Kate Chase,
but he had no style
and then there was an effort to dump Lincoln in favor of the candidate.
Jonsi Fremont.
The same frame on who would run in 1856 is the Republican presidential candidate
and Lincoln was himself all but convinced by July and early August of 64 that he
probably wouldn't win reelection.
What to do.
In the meantime,
the Democratic Party nominated George Bien Mcclellan,
former general commanding general of the army of the Potomac.
That Democratic Party in the midst of the civil war was a confusing lot and when
might even say a confused a lot,
some of them truly wanted to sue for a negotiated peace,
but they would always say they wanted a negotiated peace of the south.
It would still restore the union.
Of course,
that was never acceptable.
The Jefferson Davis and the confederate war,
uh,
the confederate government,
many of them were quite explicitly for it negotiated peace that would not result
in emancipation.
They wanted to turn emancipation around.
They want a union without emancipation.
That is exactly what Mcclellan wanted.
There was a deeply white supremacist strain and much of the northern Democratic
Party
and they put up a formidable challenge to a wartime president in the midst of
civil war.
They painted Lincoln in the Republicans as what they constantly called Miss
Educationist.
He used the term all the time,
the Republicans were going to make whites and blacks marry each other.
They called Abraham Lincoln in this campaign aid the widow maker,
and we're already waving the bloody shirt.
That would become so ubiquitous in the wake of the war planning Lincoln for all
the death.
They also referred to him as ape,
the nigger lover,
and they,
they put the democratic papers produced cartoons,
a famous cartoons or wishing,
I wish I had an example of one today or what they called miss [inaudible] balls.
These were dances and balls or whites and blacks all came together,
kissed,
made love and mixed the races.
What Lincoln desperately needed was battlefield success to alter northern warm
around.
And of course they got that.
They got,
it was the fall of mobile harbor in the first and second week of August.
I have no,
David,
Farragut and the largest naval engagement with the war took mobile,
the last major southern sea port to come into union hands.
And then especially with the fall of Atlanta and the 4th of September of 64 a
3rd of September,
sorry.
And then in the month of September,
further victories by Philip Sheridan's cavalry in the Shenandoah valley driving
confederate armies basically out of the Shenandoah valley made it now possible
to say that the war was on a course of union victory,
that the confederacy was in a state of near collapse and when the election came,
the votes were there.
Lincoln one 55% of the total popular vote,
45% of the electorate in the northern states.
It did not vote for the Lincoln
and then the fact that therefore we're not voting for emancipation.
Keep that in mind.
When we started discussing reconstruction,
18 of the of the free states made it possible for soldiers to vote at the front.
Only two did not.
And then even though it was led,
soldiers vote by absentee,
it is the first time in,
in,
in world history.
So far as we know that a republic in the midst,
there weren't that many republics.
Speaker,
of course,
the first time in the course of a,
of a civil war,
that republic held a general election and pulled it off.
Most importantly,
Blinken one,
an extraordinary 78% of the soldier vote all those hundreds of thousands in the
army and navy,
and they voted in droves.
It was that election,
a referendum on the war,
and there was a referendum on its purpose and it was a referendum.
Therefore,
on emancipation,
one of the most extraordinary events that happened in that election season was
in the third week of August of 64 Lincoln invited this time,
invited,
hey,
excuse me,
Fredrick Douglas to come to the White House.
They had met the year before in August and the 63 but that was at Douglass,
his own prodding.
63 Douglas had gone to the White House to complain about on equal pay and brutal
discrimination's against black troops in the union armies,
and you've got an audience at least for awhile with Lincoln.
The first time they met beginnings of a,
a remarkable relationship,
but in 64 Lincoln invites Douglas and Douglas didn't know what,
what he was going to be asked to do and they sat down for about 45 minutes eye
to eye and Abraham Lincoln as Frederick Douglass to lead a campaign to funnel as
many slaves out of the upper south into some kind of security in the north
before election day in November because he feared he would not be reelected than
he wanted as many slaves as possible to be secure within union lines and somehow
legally free under the proclamation before Mcclellan won the election.
Now frankly,
Douglas was stung here was a blink and asking him to be John Brown sort of,
you can hardly believe it,
and he left there.
Well,
the whole new kind of conception of Lincoln Franklin,
not entirely new,
he was already working on that,
but he went back home to Rochester,
New York and he organized about 15 or 16 agents by letter and telegram in late
August and the first week of September all over the north.
He didn't had a clue how he wasn't really going to do this or how much of the
army was really going to help him,
but he started calling all his old friends in the abolition movement and a lot
of the people who had been recruiting black troops and said,
help me,
we're going to funnel slaves out of the south.
I don't know how,
but helped me.
And then came the fall of Atlanta,
couple of Sheraton's victories in the Shannon door and the whole scheme was
called off,
but it's a measure of Lincoln's own sense of reality that he was about to lose.
All right.
The war ended of course,
in great part with the surrender at Appomattox and then with the surrender of
Joseph Johnson to Sherman and a farmhouse in central North Carolina about 10
days later,
uh,
what is it?
April 21st I believe.
Let me discuss that briefly.
It's an extremely important moment and event and the terms of that surrender are
extremely important for what's to come
in a war that had become so political,
so much about morale,
so much about public opinion,
so much about the will have two peoples to see it through
the surrender terms.
We're actually almost utterly apolitical.
I had a couple of photos up here.
I don't know if you can see this very well.
Oh,
this is one of many photographs that um,
Matthew Brady and his
troop of photographers took of Richmond after it fell April 5th 80 65 as so many
journalists now started saying the United States was finally an old country
because it had ruins.
No,
great.
You need some ruins to have a history.
Well,
Richmond fell fifth,
5th of April of 65 and Lee's army did escape.
He was experiencing tremendous desertion.
He escaped.
The goalie had as so far as we are now is to reach the Blue Ridge mountains,
maybe even get south into North Carolina,
may be hookup with Johnston's armor that was retreating in front of Sherman up
in the North Carolina.
Maybe somehow connect the two remaining confederate armies and carry on the war
if they could lead.
Really didn't ever,
ever want to give up,
but he had to.
He was cut off.
There was an emerging lethal mixture now of no supplies desertion and the almost
unfathomable over supply of the Union forces.
He was grossly outnumbered
and finally he had to send a note after this last little battle.
They actually fought on the 11th of April or 18 men were killed and there's a
little cemetery at Appomattox today where you can see the gravestones of those
18 minutes,
one of the most moving little cemeteries I've ever seen.
They're the last to die and a totally futile battle.
The terms of the surrender where essentially a this,
and by the way,
they were Lincoln's direct orders.
That's a parole slip.
It's a photocopy of exactly what they looked like.
The Union army took printing presses out to Appomattox courthouse,
which was this little town and they set it up in a tavern and they pumped out
these parole slips.
About 25 to 30,000 of them in 48 hours.
Confederate soldiers were given these parole.
They were allowed to keep their sidearms.
They had to surrender their rifles.
They were allowed to keep horses if they had them.
In essence,
they were simply told go home.
Nobody except technically Lee himself was taken into custody,
but least custody was simply the right to ride his horse back to Richmond if he
chose or wherever you want it to go.
And he was technically put under house arrest,
not allowed to leave his house or some period of time,
but never charged with anything.
Jefferson Davis.
Well more on that later,
Alexander Eight,
Steve and the vice president will technically be charged,
although never tried.
Davis will be charged but never tried.
No one except the commandant of Andersonville prison prison when captain words s
a Swiss born immigrant who command at Andersonville the worst of the south,
the prison.
It was the only person accused of treason and war crimes and executed as a
result of this war.
Now,
Lee and grant of course,
and met and Ken Burns milk this for all it's worth.
So I'm going to let you feel it from him.
Um,
they met at the Mclean House.
It happened Maddix go there some day.
It still looks almost exactly as it looked in 1865
granted,
leave barely remembered one another.
They knew each other now and all together extraordinarily well from fighting
each other for so long.
I sat down in the parlor of this house and grant gave Lee the terms lead dressed
up in his finest golden sash.
He wore his sword.
He fully expected this to be a traditional 18th or 19th century surrender.
He was going to give his sword and all that nonsense.
Grant just said,
I don't want your sword
go home.
No.
It's also true
that when they finally cut Lee's army off and Lee had to send that note and say,
please meet me,
uh,
to consider surrender terms.
The news just zoomed around.
The Union,
army and union soldiers just started going crazy,
celebrating,
screaming,
shooting off guns,
riding on their horses all over the place.
The war is over,
the war is over.
The war is over.
God,
them rebels have surrendered and grant put out an order all through his army.
If there would be no celebration.
It was grant already understanding that the surrender had to be political too
and that there would be tremendous untold bitterness
to deal with in the wake of this war grant as a general,
had no idea what politically would come.
He wasn't involved yet in reconstruction plans at all,
but it also was a kind of statement of course of honor among soldiers
to the south.
You can rest assured the day they heard about APP Maddix was the way it was for
most northerners about the day that heard of Lincoln's assassination.
It is all over diaries all over literature it sometimes it's just called the
surrender.
The day we heard there's so many statements of it throughout southern letters
and diaries.
As I've said,
I'll just read a couple just briefly and then one from a northerner to show you
what this moment means on both sides and how difficult reconstruction is going
to be.
Just look at their diaries.
Remember Kate Stone?
I read from her diary before Louisiana plant or a woman and flood over to Texas
and lost most of her slaves.
She writes into her diary.
April 28 65 all are fearful,
lead depressed.
She reports I cannot bear to hear them talk of defeat.
She still hope that confederate armies might rally and fight as she puts it to
be free or die.
Easy for her to say.
And May 15 she opened a journal entry with this definition that I may have read
before,
or the first words are conquered.
Submission subjugation.
She says out of the words in my heart,
and then when she hears the John Wilkes booth has shot Lincoln,
she rejoiced in Lincoln's death and honored at least under diary John Wilkes
booth for quote,
ridding the world of a tyrant.
We are glad he is not alive to rejoice in our humiliation and insult us with his
jokes.
It sounds as though those expressions and southern letters and diaries
that spring and summer,
an estimated eight to 10,000 next confederates,
many of the former officers would flee the country.
They ended up going to Brazil,
England,
um,
uh,
other parts of Europe,
Mexico,
Canada,
and a few.
I even went as far away as Japan for fear.
I mean Jubal early
conniving old rat.
More on him.
Later he ran to Mexico.
He was certain they were all going to be executed that at least the officer
corps of Lee's army,
none of them were.
And let me read you a diary entry from a northern woman.
Great diaries this year.
Her diaries hardly known,
but man,
her diary is almost equal to Mary Chestnut.
I first encountered it in manuscript and a Korean society,
American according to side in Wooster.
Her name was Caroline Barrett White.
She kept a diary for years,
decades and her warriors diaries extraordinary.
This is her April 10 1865 entry,
hurrah,
Hurrah,
sound allowed.
Timble over Egypt dark.
See you early this morning.
Our ears,
we're greeted with the sound of bells ringing.
A joyous peel generally had surrendered with his whole army to general grants.
She's got exclamation marks all over the place.
Surely this is the Lord's doing and it is marvelous in our eyes.
Yeah,
and she goes on and on and on.
All kinds of biblical cadences to talk about the sense of jubilation she sees in
the streets of her Massachusetts.
And then five days later,
April 15 comes this entry and it's the longest entry in her diary,
several pages and all around the outside of the pages.
She blocking the edges.
She writes the darkest day I ever remember this morning,
the sun rose upon a nation jubilant with victory,
but it sets upon one plunged into deepest sorrow.
Her longest of all diary entries.
She talked about the shocking intelligence of Lincoln's murder and then says,
where will Theresa never in the rapidity with which events crowd upon woman one
another now is perfectly bewildering
indeed.
It was
now,
as was so often the case in this war though Abraham Lincoln left one of the best
descriptions of what the Ward Ben about and the greatest speech ever delivered
by an American president.
I would venture that we could get up a debate on it,
I'm sure,
but what are you going to put up against the second inaugural for an economy of
language and the music of words and an honesty of meaning.
Read the second inaugural and it takes about three minutes.
He's been reelected.
This is march 65 war's almost over.
Not there yet.
What does he say in that speech?
What had it been about?
How does he explain all the death?
He doesn't find that easy,
but in the second paragraph and the third paragraph came,
a few phrases that we've been trying to answer through interpretation in our 65
to 70,000 books on the civil war,
more than one a day that we've written ever since.
He's thinking back to his first inaugural and he says both parties deprecated
war,
but one of them would make war rather than let the nations survive
and the other would except war rather than let it perish.
That's his interpretation.
Of course.
Just kind of get vast disagreement on that from southerners and then the famous
rays and the war came.
There are more titles of books on the civil war taken from this speech than
anything else ever done.
When in doubt,
people just go to Lincoln second inaugural and find some little phrase.
If I can find three words somebody else hasn't used before and it becomes the
title of their book
can have stamp using the war came the book on succession.
Jim Mcpherson has a new book of essays out.
It's called mighty scourge of war comes out of here.
Steven [inaudible] biography of Abraham Lincoln,
malice toward none.
I mean it's just endless.
But then in that next paragraph,
one eighth of the whole population were colored slaves
three weeks ago when Barack Obama used the word slave slavery or slaves seven
times in that remarkable speech is remarkable because it's been all together
rare that presidents or presidential candidates have ever mouthed the word slave
in American political rhetoric.
But Lincoln did
one eighth of the whole population were colored slaves,
not distributed generally over the knee,
over the union,
but localized in the southern part.
No kidding.
And here it is.
The slaves constituted a peculiar and powerful interest.
Hello,
all new says,
Lincoln,
that there's interest was somehow the cause of the war.
Somehow that's the greatest somehow in American letters,
we've been trying to explain the somehow
ever since
we never quite pin it down,
and before that paragraphs over,
you've been treated to some of the most beautiful rhetoric ever written,
at least by an American president.
He says,
everybody wished for a result less fundamental and astounding.
They didn't want all this revolution,
but that's what we got
and then comes that line
for every drop of blood shed by the lash.
It shall be paid by the sword.
You can't hear it or read it and not know what the war had been about.
Yeah,
we're going to deal in the next several lectures about the extended question of
results of this war and consequences short and long term and there are many
things we can put on that list to say the least and let me just give you a short
list to begin with and we're going to come back to so much of this
quick list.
Just keep it handy
and some of them are actually signaled and that second inaugural,
I mean one is,
it's a session was killed
almost forever.
I mean now and then you hear about the upper peninsula of Michigan wanting to
succeed or something.
Texas once in a while gets back on its heels and says,
don't mess with Texas and says they're going to succeed in some parts of the
country.
Say Go ahead.
It was a fundamental change in the nature of American nationalism and the
centralization of government that will come out of this war.
11 of the first 12 amendments to the u s constitution had been written to limit
national power.
Okay.
It's just fundamental.
It's one of Lincoln's less fundamental than astounding results.
Six is the next seven constitutional amendments will be directly to increase
federal power.
More on that as we do reconstruction.
Power itself was shift from south to north at least for a while.
In American political culture.
Nativism will be put on the run at least for a while.
Quite a while.
I mean the old native,
his party and all that nativism of antebellum America and what are you going to
do with all that xenophobia?
Nativism in the wake of a war where one of every four union soldiers was foreign
born
and now they're US citizens claiming pensions on the u s government for saving
the union.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
What native is party's going to get any traction with union veterans in the 1870
[inaudible]
none.
The labor movement and the women's rights movements on the other hand are going
to be crippled,
not ruined,
but crippled by the civil war,
by the authoritarianism of war all it's centralization
and emancipation,
of course,
ushered into national life,
all sorts of new challenges and new ideas,
new meanings,
and this most difficult American idea of all racially quality.
God,
what are you going to do with that?
Now?
It's been taken out of his barn,
shuck from its shell,
but war,
oh,
there'd be a thousand meetings.
We'll come on,
come back to six or seven of them.
No,
I want to introduce reconstruction plans here in just one moment,
but at this particular moment in time of all the possible meanings,
people are taking some of this war,
and of course they're very different meanings.
If you're one of those white Georgians who had to face Sherman's army,
or if you're Kate stone out in Texas.
Yeah.
Or if you're a widow of of your husband and four of your sons who've died in the
war.
I mean they're,
they're,
you know,
many,
many different individual stories.
But think back to what Lincoln had just said and the second inaugural about what
the war had been about and the goodest chastening that it brought the country.
One of the most remarkable documents left from this massive documentation of
this war and of emancipation is this letter.
Perhaps you've seen it before.
It's getting reprinted now.
And then it's a letter written by a former slave whose name was Jordan Anderson.
How many of you have read Jordan Anderson's letter before?
Good.
The Grad students have better?
Yes.
Well,
this isn't in the summer of 65
what are the war met Jordan Anderson had been a slave in Tennessee.
He's living in Ohio now.
The war's over.
He gets a letter from his old master who's name was Colonel Ph Anderson.
Jordan's living in Dayton,
Ohio,
and he writes back,
Colonel Anderson.
So thank you very much for your letter.
Anderson wants me to come back
dear sir,
I got your letter and was glad to find you had not forgotten old Jordan and that
you wanted me to come back and live with you again.
Promising to do better for me then anybody else can.
I have often felt uneasy about you.
I thought the Yankees would have hung you long before this for harboring ribs
they found at your house.
I suppose they never heard about.
You're going to colonel Martins to kill the union soldier that was left by his
company in their stable.
Although you shot at me twice before I left you.
I did not want to hear.
If you're being hurt and I'm glad you are still living,
it would do me good to go back to the dear old home again.
See Ms Marin,
Ms Martha,
and Alan and aster and green and Lee.
Give my love to the mall and tell them I hope we will meet in the better world.
If not in this,
I would've gone back to see you all when I was working in the Nashville
hospital,
but one of the neighbors told me Henry intended to shoot me if he ever got a
chance.
I want to know particularly what the good chance is you propose to give me.
I'm doing tolerably.
Well here I get $25 a month with victuals and clothing.
Have a comfortable home for Mandy is his wife.
The folks here at color and Mrs. Anderson and the children.
Millie Jane in Grundy go to school and are learning.
The teacher says Grundy has it had to be a preacher.
They go to Sunday school and Mandy and me attend church regularly.
We are kindly treated.
Sometimes we over here,
others saying them colored people were slaves down in Tennessee.
The children feel hurt when they hear such remarks,
but I will tell them it was no disgrace.
In Tennessee to belong to Colonel Anderson.
Many darkies would have been proud as I used to was to call you master.
Now if you will write and say what wages you will give me,
I will be better able to decide whether it would be to my advantage to make,
uh,
to move back again as to my freedom,
which you say I can have.
There's nothing to be gained on that score is that got my free papers in 1864
from the provost Marshal General of the Department of Nashville.
Mandy says she would be afraid to go back without some proof that you are
sincerely disposed to treat us justly and we have concluded to test your
sincerity by asking you to send us our wages for the time we served you.
This will make us forget and forgive old scores and rely on your justice and
friendship in the future.
I served you faithfully for 32 years and Mandy,
20 years at $25 a month for me and $2 a week for Mandy.
Our earnings would amount to $11,680 add to this the interest
for the time our wages has been kept back and deduct what you paid for our
clothing.
And three doctors visits for me and pulling a tooth for Mandy.
And the balance will show what we are injustice entitled to.
Please send the money by Adam's express care of the winters,
Esquire,
Dayton,
Ohio.
It goes on another paragraph and then as a ps,
say howdy to George Carter and thank him for taking the pistol from you.
When you were shooting at me,
what does freedom mean?
What are the war meant?
Wages with interest according to Jordan Anderson.
Well,
we'll see whether the United States would
help out old Jordan.
All right.
Now reconstruction is of course that 10 or 11 year period of American history
that sometimes too often,
I dunno how I was taught to you,
but sometimes too often we skirt through.
It's complicated and not as much glory to go is there is during the war,
it's fraught with some skulduggery and corruption on an unprecedented scale and
all kinds of sides.
It's a time of enormous imagination and experimentation and politics and law.
It's also the time in American history when we had by far our largest level of
domestic terrorism and violence.
Good deal.
More on that in the weeks to come.
Yeah.
The reconstruction policy of course began during the war.
The debate's over.
Reconstruction policy began during the war and it is
one second.
Excuse me.
Don't you hate that?
No.
What did I do?
Well,
sorry.
I had Herman Melville's poem here,
but what did I do with Herman Melville?
Forgive me.
Check that.
As the old sports announcer use design,
the policies on reconstruction took two paths and those paths begin as early as
late 1863 and there especially being debated in the federal government in 1864
and they are ripe by the end of the war in 1865
yeah.
Lincoln's basic approach to reconstruction when and if they could end the war
when the war and stop it
was to make reconstruction as fast as possible,
as lenient as possible.
Remember these three things.
You're going to hear it again as fast as possible,
as lenient as possible,
and as much as possible under presidential authority,
not congress is going to,
fashion is so called 10% plan,
which I'll explain next time,
but in essence meant that he wanted 10% of the voting pump,
the white voting population of a former confederate state to take a loyalty oath
to the Union to redraw a new constitution,
denounce the session except emancipation,
and they would be readmitted to the union under presidential authority and he
wanted to do as much of it as possible during the war because when the war ends,
he could lose his presidential war powers
in Congress,
in his own party,
led by Thaddeus Stevens in the house and Charles Sumner and the Senate and
you'll learn a good deal more about them two weeks to come.
Okay.
There's a very different approach to reconstruction.
The Cook,
the congressional radicals,
as they become known,
Republicans all want to reconstruction that is longer harsher
and under congressional control.
Oh Lincoln won't be around of course,
to engage in this battle after the war is over.
But he was there during the war and they had quite a tussle over imagining how
reconstruction,
what happened.
No.
If you want to get a sense of Lincoln's approach to reconstruction
now you can read the last paragraph is the second inaugural about malice toward
none charity for all and binding up the nation's wounds and so forth.
But there's also the statement he made in his last cabinet meeting,
the last meeting and have his cabinet before he went to Ford's theatre.
Literally that night
he said to his cabinet,
and I'm quoting,
I hope that there will be no persecutions,
no bloody work after the war is over.
No one knew you'd expect me to take any part in hanging or killing these men.
Even the worst of them frightened them out of the country,
open the gates,
let down the bars,
scare them off,
but enough lives had been sacrificed.
That's one approach,
but that is not the approach or the leaders of the congressional Republicans.
Some of them would have wished for there to be some trees and trials and
executions,
but short of that they want to reconstruction.
It's going to reshape the American polity.
Rewrite the u s constitution
and remake southern society.
Hey,
when I ever run into says reconstruction is too complicated and not interesting,
I don't understand it because how can you have that kind of thing happening and
then not be interesting but fun.
Melville,
sorry,
I'll leave you with this.
Spare the poets.
Melville wrote this little poem after Lincoln was murdered.
Listen to what he says.
Good Friday was the day of the prodigy in crime when they killed him in his
pity,
when they killed him in his prime of clemency and calm.
When we're the yearning,
he was filled to redeem the evil willed and though conqueror be kind,
but they killed him in his kindness,
in their madness,
in their blindness,
and they killed him from behind.
There is of the strong and appall upon the land,
but the people in there weeping,
bear and iron hand.
Beware of the people weeping when they bear the iron hand.
He lives in his blood,
the father and his face,
they have killed him.
The forgiver.
The avenger now takes his place.
The Avenger Wisely Stern,
who in righteousness shall do what the heavens call him too,
and the parasites remand for they killed him in his kindness,
in their madness and their blindness and his blood is on their hand.
Okay.
There is sobbing of the strong and appall upon the land,
but the people in there weeping,
bear the iron hand be where the people weeping when they bear an iron hand.
The whole history of reconstruction has always been a debate really,
or how iron the hand should have been.
Thank you.
See you next week.